prosecutors working for Special Counsel
Robert Muller now accused president
Trump's former campaign chairman that's
Paul Manafort of witness tampering
Muller's team has charged Manta Fort
with 23 counts in two different courts
including money laundering and acting as
an unregistered foreign agent now he has
pleaded not guilty
Manta Ford is one of 22 people our
company's to be charged by the special
counsel former Republican House Speaker
Newt Gingrich is a frequent critic of
Muller's investigation in his new book
Trump's America the truth about our
nation's great comeback
he writes quote this is rapidly becoming
an open-ended hunt for guilt with no
regards for the limits of the law the
former speaker joins us this morning
Newt Gingrich good morning let's talk
first we're gonna get to the book in
just a minute but let's talk about some
of the news we just outlined first Paul
Manafort president Trump's former
campaign manager now being accused by
the special counsel of witness tampering
looks like he may be going to jail well
look if it's true it's a big deal and
and I think it's an example of what
happens in these kind of cases when you
start way over here with Russia then you
go to a 2005 tax problem then you go to
not you know it was trying to be clever
when you're dealing with the FBI which
is always a bad idea and then what you
get in trouble over here with no regard
for how it started I mean people tend to
figure this is originally about Russia
we have zero evidence that Donald J
Trump in any way colluded with Russia
which is what this is all about but we
don't know because the investigation is
still underway this investigation had
been underway for twenty years that's
the way the motor is going but but
everything he's doing is about stuff
other than Russia
you are a history buff you have written
books about history let me ask you the
president yesterday broadly declared
that he has the absolute right to pardon
himself he does and then the Congress
has the absolute right to impeach him
that's what would happen I mean if a
president was dumb enough to pardon
themselves there would be such an act
this would be such an arrogant statement
of power that the house would probably
impeach him within a week and the Senate
would convicted but why do you think he
throws that out there he says it on one
hand
Trump learned in New York City media the
churning works well you know you do
something this morning and by this
afternoon you do something else and by
this evening to do something else and
everybody's busy Treach running around
chasing each other and it's he's done it
this whole career since the 1980s how
about is a former member of the
legislative branch this idea that has
the head of the executive branch he has
total control over any investigation
going on he doesn't have to show up for
a subpoena or he can just fire anybody
doing it do you bother look I think even
Rudy Giuliani he's been very aggressive
in defending him has sort of walked that
back a pretty big step I think he should
well I look I think I think if there's a
subpoena it would lead probably to a
Supreme Court test that's never been
tested and the question which several
people have said there were pretty smart
people about this does Muller really
want to end up in a Supreme Court test
that he could lose Muller or the
president no more does the president
want to be in it look what the president
I think once leashed and I happen to
strongly agree with him is to end up in
a room with Muller where Wooler and his
15 lawyers having spent months remember
we would like Trump right now to be
focusing on North Korea he's got a
summit next week
well Muller and his team a focus in the
North Korea so they're going to amass
this huge mound of data and they're
gonna walk in a room and say now when
Paige 1306 do you remember doing this
and if he makes any mistake that becomes
grounds for either obstruction or
perjury is it a problem for him to sit
with Muller when many believe that he
has trouble with the truth or that he
has trouble remembering facts or that he
has trouble changing the truth is it
that a danger for him yes for this
reason Trump is a storyteller he's an
entertainer he's a guy who and this who
he really is as a person and his whole
career he's been like this but he's
President of the United States shouldn't
the president of United States tell the
truth he should tell the truth but he
also likes to tell stories and sometimes
his stories stretch things but isn't the
question really at the center of all of
this because I went back and spent some
time with the Newt Gingrich of 1998 who
I used to cover usually say two things
above all is the president above the law
and when people complained about the
investigations into
Clinton you would say look just be
patient everything else is noise aren't
those two things to live by now
basically absolutely and as I said a
while ago I don't think he can pardon
himself I think that would lead to a
reaction in the Congress it would be
devastating I think he should tell the
truth but I also think and I said it's
from my own experience because I once
had a independent counsel who had a
million pages of my material and I watch
what happened to scooter libby and other
people you have to be extraordinarily
careful and the most they should do is
agree to written interrogatories where
if motor wants to submit in writing what
he what what questions he wants answered
the president should then submit in
writing his answers but but to get into
a room we have this again just trumps
personality
I would counts them I'm not a lawyer but
I would counsel them to be
extraordinarily cautious about ending up
in a room we have 15 hostile lawyers all
trying to get the PL play gotcha as this
question you talked about he's a
storyteller in your book you you make a
very strong case the president is
reconnecting a certain part of America
with American values right again I've
covered you I saw I read and then saw a
rendezvous with destiny which is about
Ronald Reagan you use two words to
describe Reagan character and integrity
you can't find those words in this book
about this president isn't that a
challenge when you're talking about
connecting America with core values
aren't integrity and character their
values look they're totally different
people I think you didn't the president
have this board I use I think this
president has enormous focus on big
things and has been very consistent
whether it's Iran or it's North Korea or
we now have the lowest black
unemployment rate in history and I think
it's a function of his policies he have
character and integrity to John's point
and I think he does what I think he's
very different than I think he's a
businessman he's not in the business
that you and I are in or the business
he's not a politician in a traditional
sense but as a person who's planting a
flag for American values and that we all
salute as you've described so well about
Ronald Reagan doesn't that isn't that
part of the job it is part of the job
and I would suggest you that he has done
a great deal to rebuild a belief that
America matters and that he actually
pretty aggressively
fights for what he thinks is America and
that his voters maybe not the news media
but his voters resonate to what they see
as his passion for their future okay
speaker Gingrich thanks so much for
being with us thank you